[موسيقى]
مثل جميع المدن ، تتشكل دبي من قبل أولئك
الذين يسمونها موطنًا لأكثر من 200
جنسية لكل منها ترك بصماتها على
هذه المدينة الواقعة في الشرق الأوسط على
مدار هذا البرنامج والتعرف على
المبدعين المحليين والمستكشفين الحضريين
والمغامرين المعاصرين
يرون دبي من منازلهم  وجهة نظر
[موسيقى
] الطريقة التي تغير بها فيرمي لقد أتيت من
الخلف منذ أن كنت طفلاً
أتيت إلى هنا مع كلبي
، لقد رأيت دبي تتغير من مثل
الصحراء إلى هذه المدينة الساحرة
المليئة بالحياة وكل يوم  أنا أقع في
حبها ، أنا مبتدئ ، أنا
صانع محتوى ، أول وظيفة حصلت عليها
كانت هنا في دبي ، تشعر أنك
تريد مشاركة قصتك تشعر وكأنك
تريد بناء قصتك الخاصة هنا وأنا أحب
ذلك  اعمل في صالات العرض لترى كيف
يعبر الأشخاص أو الفنانون الآخرون عن أنفسهم
ما هو الفن مثل المدينة ، هناك دائمًا
شيء ما يحدث في
شارع أفينيو مني هو مكان
يوجد فيه طعام جيد
وأشخاص رائعون وفن في دبي
خاصة عندما يتحسن
الطقس  سترى في كل مكان كل
مكان أسود يصبح فيه على قيد الحياة ،
هل يمكنني الحصول على شيء وجبن ،
إنها مسألة خبز مسطح يشبه
البيتزا لكنها بيتزا بيضاوية ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك
شارع دائري
كان مليئًا بالمرائب  مثل مرائب
السيارات وتحولت في
العامين الماضيين لتصبح مركزًا للفنانين الذين
أحب المجيء إلى هنا فقط لأستمتع بها
مع أصدقائي واستكشف فقط أحب
الرسم ، أحب الفن بشكل عام.
حول الفن ، يمكنك القدوم إلى هنا وتعلم
كيفية رسم كيفية رسم
[الموسيقى]
يتعلق الأمر بالحصول على الحرم الجامعي الخاص بك
والجلوس هنا لمدة ساعة أو أكثر فقط
الرسم للتعبير عن نفسك ، يتعلق
الأمر بمحاولة الحصول على تلك الفكرة العالقة
في رأسك و  مجرد محاولة
إخراجها بضربة واحدة أو بفرشاة واحدة فقط
بالنسبة لي ، تبدو دبي وكأنها مائة
مدينة مختلفة مجتمعة ، إنها
مصدر إلهام دائم التطور وحديث
وتاريخي ، اسمي ناتالي تشاد ، أنا
مصمم إكسسوارات
جميرا حيث نشأت ، شعرت
وكأنها قرية إلى حد ما
وأنت لست قريبًا جدًا من المدينة ،
لكنك لا تزال تعيش حياة هناك
أكثر بقليل من الاسترخاء يمكنني الركوب
على طول الشاطئ والاستمتاع بك.
أنا أتحرك على دراجة أحب أن أسمي
نفسي مهندس القابض لأنني عندما
أصمم أقوم ببناء
قطع معمارية صغيرة على نطاق صغير
وأي مكان أفضل
من أرض العمارة ذلك
التطور المستمر الذي تراه في  دبي داخل
الأفق ، يمكن أن يكون أحد التفاصيل الصغيرة
للمبنى هو الذي سيطلق مجموعة جديدة كاملة
بالنسبة لي ، إنه يلهمني أن
أهدف باستمرار لشيء أكبر ،
دبي هي بوتقة تنصهر ، وإذا انتقلت
من جزء من المدينة إلى آخر
ستجده  شيء جديد يمكنك
تناوله من فئة الخمس نجوم ، ولكن من ناحية أخرى ،
لا يمكنك العثور على طعام جيد ،
فماذا ستذهب إلى مطعم هندي أو
مطعم فارسي مثل سأبدأ
مرحبًا ، هل تفعل أيها الرجل ، بارك الله فيك ،
شكرًا لك  مخاط جدا  أنا الآن مع
مجيد ، وهو
مالك الجيل الثاني لرجل كباب خاص صغير ، أنا
جائع للغاية ،
بون أبيتيت ، شكرًا لك ليزا ، شكرًا
عندما يأتي أي شخص إلى المدينة ،
أول ما يقترحه
الناس  هو الذهاب إلى هناك لأن هذا هو
أحد أقدم المطاعم التي لديك
عائلة ملكية ستشاهد الكثير من
الصور حول العالم أحب المجيء إلى
هنا لأنه يذكرني
بالبحرين إنه مطعم فارسي ولكن
لديهم أيضًا Heine  وصفات
تعيدني إلى أن تعرف أن
المذاق ذاك الذي نشأت مع أفضل كباب
دجاج ضأن وزبادي
، خذ سلطاني وهذا هو كباب دجاج مفروم بون
أبيتيت
لذلك هذا هو خلف دجاج تكا
مقطعة بالليمون الأسود مع
يمكنك تناول الأعشاب إما مع الخبز أو يمكنك
تناولها مع الأرز ، فالأرز هنا
مميز لأنه مطبوخ
بأسعار الأعشاب مع الزعفران والتوت البري
أنا أحب الطعام هنا لأنه يتحدث
معي أنه يتمتع بشخصية مثل  من الغريب أن
نقول إن مثل الطعام له طابع شخصي
ولكنه يختلف عن ذلك ، فلا يمكنك العثور
عليه في أي مكان آخر ، إنه عمل عائلي
لرؤيتك تنمو من جيل
إلى آخر ويعيدك إلى
تلك الحالة الذهنية حيث  يعجبني
هذا ما كان عليه أن
يكون شيئًا جميلًا
عندما أريد أن آخذ قسطًا من الراحة ، أحب أن
آتي إلى منطقة فاهيتا ، فقد كان
ميناء صيدًا ثم أصبح مركزًا
للاستيراد والتصدير حيث كان كل شيء
بدأ هذا المكان بدبي وتم بناؤه من
قبل التجار الإيرانيين ، إنه لأمر مدهش أنه
لا يزال بإمكانك رؤية أبراج الرياح التي
اعتادت أن تكون مصدرًا لتكييف الهواء
هناك منتشرة في جميع أنحاء المنطقة
التي أحبها ولا يزال بإمكانك رؤية كل هذه
المواد الطبيعية وتم الحفاظ
عليها  الحجر الرملي المرجاني الذي
كانوا يتجمعون فيه من الخور بأكمله
حيث يلهمني حي الفاهيتا في
الضياع في الطرق المتعرجة
واكتشاف أماكن جديدة مثل معرض xva
، نوع الفن الذي قد تجده في
xva  متنوعًا كثيرًا في كثير من الأحيان
ستأتي إلى هنا وتكتشف
الفنانين العالميين دبي بهذه الطريقة
إنه أمر مدهش تمامًا لأنه
يجذب الكثير من الناس من العديد
من أنحاء العالم المختلفة
التي أحبها بحيث يمكننا دائمًا العودة إلى هنا
و  تواصل مع القديم ثم
عد وابق على اتصال مع
المدينة الجديدة تحرك بخطى سريعة عليك أن ترى من
أين بدأت عليك أن ترى القديم
لتتعلم منه إذا ذهبنا إلى إطار دبي
وذهبنا  إلى الأعلى إذا نظرت إلى
الجانب الأيمن فسترى التقسيم الجديد
وإذا نظرت إلى الجانب الأيسر ترى أن
هذا المكان مدهش تمامًا لأنه يظهر
لك الجانب المختلف من المدينة بأكملها
يمكنك رؤية الماضي على  يمكنك رؤية
المستقبل الذي يرغب الجميع في التقاط صور له في
دبي ، فلماذا لا نضعه في إطار ، أعتقد أن
بناء شيء كهذا أمر
مهم لأنه يوضح لك سبب
شهرة المدينة لأن
Instagram Abajo
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] للشراء  بالنسبة لي هو منظر طبيعي دائم التغير
[المصحف  ic
] يمنحني الحرية في التعبير عن
نفسي والتعبير عن حركتي على أي حال ،
اسمي هاري وأنا مدرب باركور
رياضي مع مايكل دي إكس بيف
[موسيقى]
باركور هو نظام لمحاولة
إيجاد التحدي
والتغلب عليه  راقصة ولكن بالنسبة لي لم أشعر أبدًا
أنني أستطيع التعبير عن نفسي بحرية
بالطريقة التي أردت أن أرقص بها بمجرد
أن رأيت الباركور أسرتني على
الفور ، بدأت في رؤية
المدينة وبيئتك في نقطة كانت فيها
الجدران والقضبان حواجز ذات يوم
أصبحت فرصًا للقيام بشيء
جديد ،
تجلب [الموسيقى] دبي الكثير إلى الممارسة في
مدى تكيفها وتغييرها
طوال الوقت ، ولا
يقدم موقعان عمومًا نفس الخيارات بالنسبة لنا
[موسيقى]
منطقة دبي للتصميم وعلى
وجه الخصوص الكتلة الموجودة هنا  مكان رائع
وملهم للوحة الحديقة
، مستويات مختلفة من الجيران
لاستكشاف ارتفاع أكبر قليلاً ،
تختلف ممارستي على مدار الأسبوع
أحيانًا أخرج أشعر بمزيد من المرح في وقت ما
تجد مكانًا جديدًا
يسعدك عندما تتجول في المرسى ،
فلديك أعمال من حولك يحاولون جميعًا
أن يكونوا فريدًا جدًا وهذا يوفر لنا
بعد ذلك منطقة كثيفة من المواقع الأصغر
التي تنوع المدرب كثيرًا هناك ،
يا رفاق عندما  لقد وصلت لأول مرة إلى دبي ،
من الأشياء التي أحببتها حقًا
أنني تمكنت من السير على الشاطئ
ورؤية الأشخاص يمارسون الرياضة بجانب
ذلك المسار ، هناك توازن جيد هنا
مع نمط حياة بدني يجعل
الأشخاص النشطين يتحركون بشكل صحيح
منذ سن مبكرة عندما نكون في مجموعة ،
إنها حالة ارتداد بعضنا البعض
والعمل معًا لبناء
أشياء مختلفة ، كل شخص لديه أسلوبه الخاص
في الباركور ، إنها طريقة رائعة
لدفع نفسك إلى ما وراء حدودك العادية.
أعتقد أن
مكانًا مثيرًا للاهتمام
ينمو فيه مجتمع ما ، فإنه سينقلب في المقدمة من هذا
الشيء ، تصبح المدينة مكاننا
لتدريب مكاننا على التواصل الاجتماعي
لتطوير أنفسنا في أي مكان في
كل مكان يصبح pla  CE بالنسبة لنا
للتسكع وممارسة
[الموسيقى]
هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي يجب على دبي
تقديمها لأي شخص لديه اهتمام أو
رياضة يريد أن ينموها ، اسمي
تيموثي يان
أعيش في دبي منذ
18 عامًا  لقد أتاح لي العيش في دبي
أن أحب استكشاف مختلف الرياضات المتطرفة
لأن هذا هو ما أشعر به أكثر
ما تكتشفه أن هناك الكثير من
الجبال والأبيض كما يكمن
في الخطر جبال
حتا هو جانب مختلف تمامًا من دبي
فهو 130 فقط  على بعد كيلومترات ، هناك
أنواع مختلفة من الأنشطة التي
يمكنك القيام
بها ، إنها مكان مريح بالنسبة
لي عندما أهرب من المدينة
[موسيقى]
عندما أذهب إلى الفخ ، فأنت تشعر
بالراحة حقًا وتركز فقط
على رفاهيتك.  لقد كنت في جبلين
على مدى السنوات الأربع الماضية ، لقد تسلقت الآن
حول العالم ستة عشر جبلًا أنا
أستمتع حقًا بذلك وأحب العثور على
مسارات جديدة واكتشاف ما هناك ،
أعتقد حقًا أننا بحاجة إلى الطاقة التي
نحصل عليها كبشر من الهواء الطلق
نحن الآن في نصف سد حيث
يأتي الناس إلى هنا للتجديف بالكاياك ، إنه
مكان مثالي للتواجد بالخارج للحصول على بعض الهدوء
في الماء بين الجبال ،
سنكون جميلين ،
دعنا نذهب
بمجرد وصولك إلى السد ، الماء
يتجمد ، إنه طبيعي تمامًا
المطر الذي ينتهي بك الأمر برؤية
أنواع مختلفة من الحياة البرية لمدة ثلاث ليالٍ للخروج
هنا خارج المدينة مباشرةً وتأتي
إلى هذا المكان الجميل ، يمكنك بالفعل
بناء شغف هنا بسبب
كمية الخيارات المتاحة لك من حيث
الأنشطة لتجربة الاتصال  مع
الطبيعة
ربما تظل إيجابيًا ، نتطلع إلى
ما يجب القيام به بعد ذلك ، بالإضافة إلى أن
تحدي أنفسنا أمر مهم جدًا لأنفسنا
[الموسيقى]
بالنسبة لي ، فإن قلب دبي هو
الفرصة التي كنا قريبين جدًا من
كل مكان يقع فيه جغرافيًا في
وسط العالم  الكثير من الرحلات
عبر الإمارات العربية المتحدة لدرجة أنها تعطيني الكثير من
الإلهام الموسيقي ، والفجوة التي
أراها هي الوطن ، إنها ليست وجهاتك الصيفية
وليست وجهتك الشتوية
أنا في المنزل ، اسمي داني
نيفيل وأنا مذيع راديو دي جي
موسيقي
لأني ديجاي حول العالم
ولأنني في الحفلات الموسيقية والمهرجانات في
50000 بالنسبة لي أنا أقدر
وأنا وأنا نتوق إلى
بيئات أكثر حميمية مثل  كوف دبي
على الشاطئ ، نعم إنه في قصر قيصر ،
إنه فخم ولكن الشعور به
تذهب إلى هناك وتجلس هناك وتجلس هناك 200
شخص 150 شخصًا ، وهذا هو نوع
البيئة التي أستمتع بكونها منتعشة
أشعر وكأنني في بلدي  الفناء الخلفي مع
مجموعة من الأصدقاء الذين تريد أن
تسمعوا حقيقة دبي ، اذهبوا إلى أماكن جديدة
واستمتعوا بالعشاء وأظهروا هؤلاء
الأشخاص واستمعوا إلى قصتهم ،
الحياة الليلية في دبي بالنسبة لي لا تشبه أي شيء
رأيته في أي مكان في العالم
يمكنك ''  لنقول دبي وأكون مثل أوه ، إنهم
ضخمون في موسيقى الريغي أو أنهم ضخمون في
قاعة الرقص أو أنهم ضخمون على الإنترنت
لأن هناك شيئًا للجميع
لا يسيطر عليه الجميع
في أيام السبت الحضرية البيضاء ما زلت أشعر
بالقلق من أنني أقوم بحفل موسيقي
يحافظ عليه  م  هذا يبقيني على أصابع قدمي ، ما زلت أشعر
بالفراشات في بطني
لأنني أقف هناك أمام 2000
شخص ، لكنني أشعر أن
الأدرينالين مجرد وحش جميل ،
إنه تجربة أكثر من كونه نادٍ
أعتقد أنه صنعه  علامة على
الحياة الليلية وفي دبي والشرق
الأوسط ،
أوه ، يمكن لدبي التعامل مع أكثر من ألفي
مكان بسعة أكبر ، فلنفعل ذلك عندما
أجد نفسي في هذه الدورة الفخمة
ونقوم بأشياء كبيرة ، وأتراجع خطوة
إلى الوراء وأتوجه إلى  المناطق غير المكتشفة
في دبي ،
إذا ذهبت لتناول الشاي في
مكان قريب من المدرسة القديمة ، وهذا
يعيدني إلى الجذور ، فهذه هي المناطق
التي شكلت لنا الكحوليات هي نوع
المنطقة في دبي التي تجعلك تشعر بأنك
نمت محليًا مصانع صناعية في كل
مكان  شاحنات
تمر بالجوار ثم تجد بابًا صغيرًا لطيفًا تذهب
إليه وهناك مثل أحذية رياضية لمرة واحدة
وأنت مثل رائع كيف انتقلنا من هذا
إلى هذا
هذا ما اخترته لذلك نحن هنا من
الأفضل أن نطير بهذا  هو أول من  من نوعه
في المنطقة التي ولدت وترعرعت في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
لم يكن لدينا حقًا شيء مثل هذا من
الناحية الثقافية ، لم يكن هناك مكان استراحة بالنسبة
لنا للحضور وتجربة
أحذية رياضية عصرية ، كل هذه ضربات سريعة ، كل
هذه الضربات لمرة واحدة حتى تعرف كل
حذاء رياضي في  هنا قصة ،
قد لا تكون الأغلى ثمناً ، لكن من
المؤكد أن لديها قصة وراءها
عندما بدأ علي تزلجًا بالتأكيد
منح أطفال الإمارات العربية المتحدة مكانًا
للتسكع والشعور
بالراحة والشعور بالراحة والبرودة ، أعتقد أن الأمر
يتعلق بـ  كان جمع
[الموسيقى]
flipside مفهومًا تم إنشاؤه
لجمع المجتمع معًا عشاق الموسيقى
الذين يقدرون الثقافة التناظرية
أعتقد أن السبب في أن مكانًا مثل
flipside يعمل جيدًا هنا هو أننا
نشأنا في صراع للعثور على الفينيل
ثم تمشي في  ضع مثل هذا في
وسط كل ذلك ، كل ما يعيدك
إلى الأرض ويذكرك نوعًا ما
بهذه الطريقة التي نشأنا بها جميع المعدات
، يستخدم جميع منسقي الأغاني الآن كل شيء رقميًا ولكن
بالنسبة لنا نحن الرجال  موسيقى دي جي مبتذلة في
التسعينيات ، أشعر وكأننا ما زلنا نرغب في اللعب على
الفينيل ، لذلك نختار إحساس الشمع
ونخرج هنا من وقت لآخر ،
وهذا مكان اجتماعي آخر حيث
نلتقي بالعديد من الأشخاص ذوي التفكير المماثل
وهذا سوف  ألهمني لأخذها
وأعمل على شيء من منظور الإنتاج
نشجعه على العودة إلى التناظرية
والعودة إلى الجذور ، سأعود
إلى ما جعلني أقع في حب الموسيقى
والجهاز ، فأنا أحب كل
ما أصبحت عليه دبي  لننظر إلى الوراء في السنوات
الخمس والعشرين الماضية ونرى ما تمكنت من
تحقيقه عندما تمكنت من التجول حول العالم
والتحدث إلى الناس من خلال الموسيقى التي
لم يتم القيام بها في ميامي ، ولم يتم ذلك في
نيويورك ، وقد تم ذلك في دبي
دبي هي طاقة جميلة تسمعها
بما فيه الكفاية إنها فيجاس
الشرق الأوسط ولكنك لا تسمع ما يكفي من
الأنشطة الرائعة في الهواء الطلق
الثقافة والموسيقى الفنية ، إنها جميلة
فقط تعرف على قلب
[الموسيقى] الإلهي